私は今日
生まれ変わる
こんなに朝早く起きて
東京に行くのには理由がある。
今日もひどい前髪だ
下駄を履いている
ひどい睡魔とともに私は
お土産屋さんでお土産を購入した。
そのまま新幹線乗り場に向かい
新幹線に乗る。
席に座った瞬間…
すぐ寝る。
私が向かう先はただ一つ
伝説の美容室
この荒れ果てた髪型を修繕すべく
最強の美容師軍団に
髪の毛カットを依頼することにした。
生まれ変われ！
俺の！
魂！
いやほんと、なんとかして下さいちょっと
あ、何か
カウンセリング資格もいいすかね（？）
あっカウンセリングですか？
あっもう
＄＃＠％
シャンプー行きましょ
えっもるさんがすんの？
はい
わっやべぇ緊張する
めっちゃ久しぶりっすね
いやぁもるさん久しぶりだねぇ
＄＃＠％
これずっと回してるんすか？
うんｗずっと回してるｗ
あ〜やべ
シャンプーしていきます
よろしくお願いします。
お願いします。
起こしていきます。
ありがとうございます。
どんな感じにしたいとかありますか？
えーと、ひとまず〜
前髪をなんとかしたいという
色は明るい方がいい暗い方がいいありますか？
迷ってるんですよ〜
明るいほうが良いのかなー？
お願いします。
はい　よろしくお願いします。
切るのも久々な感じですね
久々ですね〜
あぁ！すみません
＄＃＠％
前髪以外は久しぶりです…
前髪…これは…
動画で持ってかれて…
結構伸びた方ですよでも
ここ激軽(?)ですね
もうっ　あの
世界一のイケメンにして下さい
前髪すごいやばいっすね
あぁ　これは、
やばいなぁ
揃ってるのが多分よろしくないですよね
幅も全然違うんで
結構やばめです
お気の向くままに
うわ！うわうわ
ヤンキーヤンキーヤンキー
ヤンキーヤンキーｗ
うわー
僕、去年金髪だったんでしばらく
うわー懐いなーこれくらいだったなー確か
就寝です
おー！ありがとうございます！
すごい！前髪がなくてもここまで人は…
進化できるんですね！
おおー！
な、何色？
ピンクっぽい
緊張されてると逆にやりずらいっていうｗ
緊張しますよ！もう(照)
結構バッサリ短くしました。
ありがとうございます！お疲れ様でした。
はい！どうも〜
というわけでですねえっと〜
とんでもねえ髪型を
無事なんとか
かなり！
カッコよくさせていただきました
本当に今日はありがとうございました。
どうでしたかこの前髪は
いやぁ 難しかったねぇ
まぁ ぜひ伸ばして下さい。
頑張ります。
この機会に是非みなさん
OCEAN TOKYO Harajuku 遊びに来て下さい。
是非！是非！
是非！
お待ちしてます！
あれ？
もう使う気ですねこれ
いやっ使わないっす